c'est pas un tribunal ici difficile pour
ces élèves de 5e du collège albert
einstein de deviner où il se trouve
christine mercier première adjointe de
la mairie leur fait découvrir le conseil
municipal
c'est important qu'ils sachent ce qu'il
ya dans leur commune mais surtout
comment ça fonctionne et leur montrer
que ça fonctionne de la même manière
partout et c'est important c'est ça fait
partie de la citoyenneté 30 minutes des
changes pour apprendre qu'il ya 29
conseillers municipaux dont huit
adjoints au maire durant une semaine les
citoyens de demain vont à la rencontre
des acteurs de la commune de quoi
peut-être susciter des vocations
il y avait quelque chose que je lis déjà
mais la plupart un an
c'est plus tard on aimerait bien par
faire le même métier ou postuler bas au
moins on sait à peu près les bases je
savais pas qu'on pouvait assister aux
réunions
or vote et que
il y avait beaucoup de
deux fonctionnaires qui travaillent ici
la semaine de la citoyenneté concerne
tous les élèves du cp au collège un
enfant devrait rassembler tous les
acteurs en avril 2018